Russian tanks rolling across the border in southern
Ukraine air strikes hitting large cities and thousands of
people attempting to flee the Ukrainian capital,
Kiev footage from Ukraine shows scenes of war after President Putin
announced a military operation in the country.
Everyone here is shocked.
Everyone here knew that this might be coming for months.
It was predicted and discussed and now that it's here,
it's very hard to fathom.
And people here,
a lot of them have fled,
but a lot remains.
Ukrainian officials said,
strikes,
targeted military installations,
air fields and government facilities across the country.
Air raid sirens blared in Kiev after President Putin's statement was broadcast
In the early hours of February 24,
Ukrainian President Vladimir Zelensky declared martial law and called for global
assistance.
President biden called the move unjustified pledging new actions against
Russia.
The EU said it would hit Moscow's financial sector,
freezing assets and banning the export of technology to the country.
We will weaken Russia's economic base and its capacity to
modernize the United Nations condemned Russia's moves during a meeting of the Security
Council late Wednesday.
This is the saddest
moment in my china,
the Secretary general of the United Nations President Putin in the name of
humanity,
bring your troops back to Russia.
President Vladimir Putin of Russia said his goal is to
hold Ukraine's leaders to account and and put them on trial for the
last eight years of events in in Donbas,
we don't know.
The end game is yet um but as troops enter from
various directions and as airstrikes continuing all over the
country.
It does seem possible that that Russia's goal is to make its way
to Kiev,
the capital in order to take over Ukraine.
Yeah.